the city in Greece which may lead is
amazing so we're looking forward the
apartment on the Acropolis to anything
in the wrong however we do have a lot of
Greek architecture including the large
columns on the animal house from another
good example is the statue of Athena of
the classic center even hosted some
events the 1996 Summer Olympics averages
home to the University of Georgia
founded by a land grant 75 and opened
the glasses in Asia no one it is the
oldest public university in the country
these arches I'm stand by our symbol of
University and basically arches on
Carlos state seal this beautiful 614
acre campus is not only below for
academics but it's athletics as well the
university is home to the Georgia
Bulldogs or the most popular collegiate
teams in the south our football team
considered the national champions in
1942 at nineteen eighty as one of the
most enthusiastic bands he could find
especially when we're playing Harbor
Florida or Georgia Tech our hearts
vitals the dogs are in town
I'm 2476 teach at Stanford Stadium get
filled up Adams social schedule here in
Athens this is what it's all about this
is a double no reasons
never actually saw that but it still
stands to this day when is the North
just case you can find this local
curiosity by next or historic city hall
this is ana star Jenna theater was a
badly damaged by fire last year as in
the possibly Builder theme college town
island has a very vibrant culture is the
birthplace of such bands as REM why is
their tenant in the beef accused men in
which haven't forward to doing here the
downtown district is home to great
shopping and dining in our city is now
home around the world making Athens a
diverse mini an overall great place to
live in hey I geo that you know that
even though George is called the Peach
State ring behind California and South
Carolina peach reduction nevertheless we
have a Peachtree City Beach County 71
streets in Atlanta with P Street in it
peaches on our license plates and an
annual peach drop on year's eve even
have peaches and our portable toilets so
even though you don't produce as much as
you can clearly see we still observe the
title if I was in charge of the roof for
one day I will do most is alight get a
worldwide permanent ban on a more
serious note out in all forms of hatred
discrimination and Prejudice and exist
in our world today conflict and
terrorism arise from such terrible ideas
so by doing this mr. didn't turn create
a more peaceful world a world where
governments could says had the
differences and work towards combating
climate change poverty disease and other
problems in human race Hayden's so how
about grandma let stuff into my head
like most people competing the govt I'm
not suddenly competing for the fame and
glory of winning because I'm truly
interested in geography I'm competing
the BIA test my knowledge and have fun
if you're not into geography remembering
all the information can seem really hard
but for someone who has a real passion
and curiosity for geography so seems to
come naturally my only tip is to read as
much as you can and ring with a passion
it also helps if you compete in the be
as much as you can and learn from your
mistakes I know I have in the five years
I competed
so wish me luck as I represent the state
of Georgia and I hope I can inspire do
the same one day too
you